- What do Rihanna
and the Red Hot Chili
Peppers have in common?
A deep admiration for Brandy Norwood.
She's been called your favorite
singer's, favorite singer.
The artist known as the "Vocal Bible",
is both a Grammy winner
and television star.
Brandy has had many highs in her career
and was the "It" girl in
the '90s and early 2000s.
But even still, Brandy's vocal talent
and innovation are not recognized enough.
So we are gonna talk about it.
(people talking simultaneously)
Brandy was only 14 years old
when she recorded her first single,
"I Wanna Be Down".
The minimal arrangement combined
with her impressive vocal chops,
won over the hearts of R&B
and pop listeners alike.
("I Wanna Be Down" starting)
What do you think made Brandy
stand out early in her career?
What do you think made her pop?
- So I think there is
this very polished look
that was super intentional,
in this innocence,
that made her very loving.
So that worked with her tone.
Brandy, it's only one tone.
- Well, you know it out
of a thousand voices.
- She is just, she's a quiet storm.
- But Brandy didn't reach that
level of success overnight.
Born in 1979, she spent
most of her childhood
in Carson, California.
Brandy's father was a a gospel singer
and a minister of music.
- Yes, that's right.
Brandy got her musical
foundation in the church.
She even started singing
in the church choir
at the age of two.
Brandy's life was changed
after seeing Whitney Houston
on TV for the first time.
She remembers telling her mom,
"I wanna be as big as Whitney Houston."
By the time she was 12 years old,
she was already singing backup
for the teen R&B group, Immature.
And it took her only a year or two
to land her own record deal with Atlantic.
- It's important to remember
that the musical landscape
of the 1980s looked nothing
like we're used to today.
Labels struggled to
find mainstream success
with young black women stars.
There were a few artists
who let off their mark like
Tracy Spencer, Penny
Ford, and Janet Jackson.
But even they struggled to break out
of the R&B charts and cross over to pop.
- Between white artists infusing pop
with R&B elements and black
artists getting closer
to mainstream than ever before,
Brandy had a real shot
at becoming a superstar.
And Brandy did become a superstar.
In 1997, she starred in Cinderella,
alongside her hero, Whitney Houston.
She got her own TV show,
Moesha, sold Barbie dolls,
and even cut a deal with CoverGirl.
- So how did Brandi grow
into a heavy weight?
And what makes her voice so special?
It all starts with her greatest
influence, Whitney Houston.
You can hear the Whitney
influence in her debut album
with songs like "Baby",
("Baby" starting)
- or "Broken Hearted".
("Broken Hearted" starting)
- I feel like she was able
to use Whitney Houston
as kind of her launching pad
into being a lot more inventive
and a lot more thoughtful and, okay,
where else can I go, musically?
- In what ways do you hear
that Whitney influence in her music?
- You know, if you, if you really go back
and you listen to a lot of her ballads,
♪ Broken ♪
All of that's Whitney.
If you listen to that and
you put it side by side with
♪ I believe in you and me ♪
it's the same vocal style.
- Yeah. And that, my
favorite one is the one
it's the one that's like,
♪ Let me live just so I can sing
for you, sounds like Brandy ♪
- Yeah. You know, it sounds
like, if Whitney were still
making music, something
that she would be doing.
- Exactly.
- [Male Narrator] Collaborating
with acclaimed musicians
like Rodney Jerkins,
and late vocal producer, LaShawn Daniels,
Brandy implemented a vocal style
that felt effortless to the listener.
("The Boy is Mine" starting)
- Brandy's vocal agility, fast vibrato,
and crystal clear runs
soon became her trademark.
Rather than testing the
limits of her belting power
and vocal range,
Brandy focuses on her
mid-register with great control.
("Long Distance" starting)
- [Woman Narrator] Taking
inspiration from jazz singers,
she often utilizes the
mixed voice approach,
by mixing her chest
voice and her head voice.
She brings an airy and buttery
quality to her singing.
("Should I Go" starting)
- [Male Narrator] Perhaps this is one of
the reasons why her voice still sounds
as flexible as ever today.
Even when she belts,
she does so with care.
She knows exactly how
long to sustain a note
and how soon to descend off of it.
♪ When you look at that
picture, la, so, la. ♪
You know?
- That's fire, that's fire.
- Her use of tensions
and knowing how to like,
use an approach note, you know,
and then like a suspension.
So, and later years "Full Moon",
"Full Moon" she literally,
(singing notes)
While the chord is just
doing all the things!
(narrator singing)
(singing in unison)
The woman is singing down.
- Like many R&B singers,
Brandy is also a fan of adlibs.
She often adds to the story of each song
by inserting new melodic layers
to top off the main theme.
("Bordline" starting)
- Every element feels intentional
and it intensifies the emotional
impact on the listener.
Grammy award winning
gospel singer songwriter,
Erica Campbell said it best,
"It's a perfect marriage
of vocal and lyric".
- Brandy is piano, Brandy
is a string section.
- Oh wow.
She, her arrangements are arrangements.
They're pads.
- Orchestrations.
- Or an orchestration like, it's,
you could strip away all instrumentation
of a Brandy song and have a full song.
- There's a reason why many
consider Brandy's third
album to be her greatest body of work.
In "Full Moon",
it was time to showcase
the depth of her abilities.
- Brandy said she believed the track,
"What About Us" could change the game.
The offbeat, futuristic
song took influence
from hiphop and dance pop.
("What About Us" starting)
- Rodney Jerkins had a
field day on "Full Moon".
And if you listen to "Full Moon",
if you is the very first song
on there called, "I Thought",
("I Thought" starting)
you'll hear the way that he
used that same production
on "Feedback" for Janet Jackson,
four or five years later.
("Feedback" starting)
- Rodney Jerkins
literally found his sound,
in my opinion, on the
Brandy "Full Moon" album.
- Okay.
- Brandy is an, is a singer that producers
can find their sound in.
- [Woman Narrator] As
she was in the studio
finishing up the
production of "Full Moon",
Brandy found out that she was pregnant
with her daughter Sy'rai.
- [Male Narrator] Now
the mother of a toddler
in her twenties, Brandy
was ready to show the world
what adulthood looked
like through her eyes.
First, she said goodbye to
her longtime collaborator,
Rodney Jerkins, and
brought in Timbaland to
produce her fourth studio
album "Aphrodisiac".
- [Woman Narrator] In this album,
Brandy's voice sounds
more raw than ever before.
Boldly referencing Coldplay in "I Try",
this classic R&B tune
aligns Brandy's adlibs
with her building frustration and regret
in the face of infidelity.
("I Tried" starting)
- With the release of "Aphrodisiac",
Brandy's vocal trinity
was finally complete.
Between "Never say Never",
"Full Moon" and "Aphrodisiac",
she provided the perfect
guidebook for R&B artists
for many years to come.
- Given the plethora of female artists
now dominating the game,
it's easy to forget how it all began.
Solange once said,
"Brandy is a goddess in
R&B to a lot of people.
She is really the foundation for a lot
of this very innovative,
progressive experimental R&B.
Brandy influenced a lot of that."
- There's a reason why Solange,
one of the most experimental
R&B artists of today,
puts Brandy on a pedestal.
Nowadays, it's common to
hear singers use their voices
in unconventional ways,
but back when Brandy was on her way up,
that approach was practically unheard of.
- Okay. So I have a question
that I'm nervous to ask you,
but can you teach me some of
Brandy's vocal techniques?
- Oh my gosh. Yes. What
song are we gonna do?
(women screaming excitedly)
- Oh! I dunno.
- Okay, so my favorite song,
one of my favorite songs
is, When You Touch Me".
♪ Really miss you, baby. ♪
- Okay.
- So you wanna be really specific
about where you put vibrato
when it comes to singing Brady.
- Okay.
Okay. It's gonna be challenge for me
to not sing with vibrato.
♪ Really miss you, baby. ♪
Oh. I caught myself.
- Vibrato isn't a bad thing.
It's just not true to Brandy's aesthetic.
It's like, it's so specific in our world.
We call it "chiaroscuro",
the blend of light and dark.
Like, it's just different for her.
It's really unique.
It doesn't really go by the standard.
Like, you can tell she took the standard
and kind of have modified
it for her signature sound.
- Today, Brandy is evidently still working
on expanding her range,
showcasing a few previously
unheard falsetto tones
on songs like "I Am More".
("I Am More" starting)
- R&B is a huge part of
mainstream pop music today.
In part, thanks to Brandy
propelling the genre forward
during a time where black
female artists were all
but missing from the charts.
Her TV shows, movies,
and endorsement deals
helped her reach role-model status,
but it was her musical excellence
that cemented her legacy.
Thanks for tuning in
to our Brandy episode.
A friend of mine and the creator
of "Sound Field" has
started in a new project
inspired by "Sound Field"
that goes beyond music.
I'll let Joseph tell you about it.
- Working on "Sound Field" inspired me to
create a new PBS documentary
series called "Subcultured",
which explores how
lesser-known communities have
influenced the mainstream
culture around us.
I've met with a blind gamer
who plays Mortal Kombat professionally.
I've met cowboys and
cowgirls from the gay rodeo.
And I've also explored how anime became
a $25 billion industry.
- Check it out on the PBS
voices link in our description
and let them know that
Sound Field sent you.
- Here are your submissions
from our last video
when we asked you what your
favorite pop-punk song is.
- "Ever Fallen In Love" by
the Buzzcocks is perfect
and I could look to it
every day until I die.
- As always thanks for watching.
We wanna hear what your
favorite Brandy vocal moment is.
If you'd like, you can submit a video
of yourself telling us your favorite songs
at the link in the description.
(upbeat music fading)